good evening everyone I hope you had a
great Thanksgiving weekend I'm Laura
Ingram this is Ingram angle from
Washington tonight thanks for joining us
with just 50 days can you believe it
until the Iowa caucuses well the polls
are tightening nationally Governor Ronda
santis is making a stop right here on
the angle but first money for nothing
that's the focus of tonight's
angle all right unless you're the son of
a president and are able to charge what
$300,000 or so for art that looks like
it should be hanging in a middle school
hallway you know the Biden economy it's
in the
pits how is the economy in your estimate
it's horrible the economy is very bad
right now the cost of everything is very
expensive we don't spend the money like
we used to I just spend more obviously
I'm spending a whole lot more I'll spend
what I usually spend but it it probably
won't buy nearly as much well the facts
are undeniable even the Biden friendly
media can't avoid reporting the truth
any any longer from Bloomberg today
groceries are up 25% used cars climb 35%
rent it's only up 20% now while
Americans daily routines have largely
returned to their pre-pandemic normal
the cost of living has not from the
Atlantic houses are unaffordable for
middle class families across the country
rural areas are expensive suburbs are
expensive cities are absurdly expensive
nowhere is cheap that's in part thanks
to mortgage rates the monthly payment on
a new home has increased by more than
50% in the past 3 years from The Wall
Street Journal its new survey shows that
the belief in the American dream is
dying just 36% of Americans This was so
heartbreaking to see over the weekend
said it's still possible if you work
hard the American dream 45% said it was
true but not anymore and 18% said it was
never True by the way that's double what
it was previously that's a big drop
though from the other surveys in 2012
and 2016 were 53% and 40 uh uh 6%
respectively still believed overall in
The American Dream all of this is bad
news for Democrats because women were
more pessimistic than men while younger
people were much more pessimistic than
people over the age of 65 now remember
women and young voters are key Biden
constituencies that's not good for him
so hardworking Americans have good
reason to be frustrated very frustrated
we're seeing it in the gas prices is
we're seeing it in in the economy and
how we're spending our money I think
inflation is impacting people very
negatively our dollar is going a lot
less this year than it did last year it
costs money just to wake up every day W
no wonder Donald Trump's numbers keep
getting stronger and Biden's are getting
weaker which makes it all the more
baffling that the Democrats refuse to
change their policies they refuse to
shut the board they refuse to cut
spending they refuse to unleash the
energy sector instead the only thing
they're doing is strategizing The
Washington Post reporting on meetings
convened by Biden's Chief of Staff with
the economic and comms teams in an
effort to turn around the narrative and
then debunk what they believe are
misleading social media reports like the
one about the $16 Big Mac on Tik Tock
which circulated last year and is still
ricocheting around the internet the Big
Mac conundrum reflects what Biden AIDS
and Senior Democratic officials regard
as one of their most vexing challenges
ahead of the 2024 presidential election
even as inflation has fallen to a
manageable 3% and although the labor
market has remained hot and with strong
growth voters still don't like the
economy and they blame the president H
but the President says come on kids you
got it all wrong from Turkey to air
travel to tank of gas cost went down
they went down now if people making a
lot of money that doesn't matter a whole
lot because the costs are relatively
small compared to wealthy incomes in
fact as a share of earnings this
Thanksgiving dinner was the fourth
cheapest ever on
record okay so unconvincing the fourth
cheapest I don't know how they determin
that but it's especially unconvincing
when he falls back on blaming companies
that do what all businesses do to stay
alive when costs go up they have to pass
increased cost especially now energy
costs onto consumers let me be clear to
any Corporation that's not brought their
prices back down even as inflation's
come down even as Supply chains have
been rebuilt it's time to stop the price
gouging and give the American Consumer a
break are his eyes even open on that but
by the way it's spoken as a man who's
never run a business in his life or had
to actually make a payroll and when all
else fails you you can always just blame
Trump magga republicans in Congress are
pushing back on our efforts to end these
junk fees
fortunately uh we've been able to push
back on Republican Maga Republicans so
far but they haven't given up they
haven't given up they still want to undo
this progress we're
making junk fees really now I think he
meant undoing the not the progress the
regress he does not give a darn about
what he's done to this country and we
know the Biden's they won't need to
pinch pennies this Christmas Hunter and
Jim after all they're making all their
foreign cash they'll make sure of that
but how has the Biden economy affected
the holidays of regular
Americans I'm only buying what people
need not what they want really why
because of the economy yes because of
the economy everything is high very
expensive well Biden says everything's
cheap this year see he doesn't comport
and by the by the way to think that the
White House thinks women like that
should be happy with the state of things
she just must not understand that thinks
are great how
insulting what happened to The
democrat's Compassion Surplus that they
always claimed they had that like
everything Biden campaigned on was a lie
and next November the voters will
finally have the chance to make these
arrogant incompetent and corrupt people
pay and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else